[Musique]
sur quand même des volumes comme vous
pouvez le voir avec une exposition sud
sud ouest
donc plutôt lumineux vous en pensez que
c'est super j'aimerais bien de l'autre
on est d'accord vous avez un dossier
oui oui je peux vous montrer tout de
suite un est parfait on va checker ça
ensemble carte d'identité à ça c'est le
seul truc je peux vous l'envoyer par
mail on revient de falloir les trois
derniers bulletins de paie sachant qu'il
faut justifier d'un salaire trois fois
et demi au dessus du loyer à on est
quand même sur 2 845 euros hors charges
walesa j'ai pris 4 blanc plus ça me
permet d'arriver au montant tout juste
vous avez des garants oui cette juste
test hiv négatif absolument une
photocopie sa annonce un papier carbone
ah ça c'est encore non ça se fait plus
mais je les fais faire exprès pour
donner un peu de cachet à mon dossier
face et bien ça fait toujours un petit
peu classe très bien vu taris pour moi
on arrive très bien joué c'est un
cendrier en coquillages absolument cet
avion en papier mâché
un peu de mauvais goût mais ça passe
alors une photo dédicacée de francis
lalanne vous y connaissez en d'abs mondy
dame non ou bien joué un tatouage de
mauvais goût c'est bien dégueu quand
même que ça abonne toi
joran une mauvaise imitation bruce
willis police de new york
ipic aller en forêt bonne imitation de
philippe manoeuvre et c'est en 75 que
michael jackson fait la rencontre de
paul mccartney est joué c'est un clone
de vous même ça fait un clin d'oeil
original une intervention à justifier de
mon propre père jean rudolf apec tamam
on est un peu de temps en temps quand
même ça lui fera plaisir
ok c'est bon je suis appelé un tapis de
souris en peau de souris un millefeuille
en feuille d'érable le calumet on
allumait dont vous et puis moi mais bien
sûr le classique une plume de faucon
pas évident à choper mais je lai bon bah
écoutez je crois que je crois qu'on a
tous dans le dossier là c'est bon j'ai
la partie allait ok pour vous
[Musique]
et c'est lucien tu as bien aimé ce
sketch et ben tu peut en retrouver
d'autres de moi sur ma chaîne perso et
pour ta bonne et bah c'est simple il a
même pas besoin de dossiers tu cliques
et si tu as envie de me retrouver sur
scène c'est aussi possible parce que tu
sais quoi le 14 janvier à l'olympia et
ben golden moustache fait une soirée en
live quoi s'est il est ou pas
[Musique]